今日は自分を騙してしまう心の機能についてお話しします
かなり前なんですけど
同じテーマで話をしましたから
その話を聞いた方にとっては面白くないかもしれません
このテーマは
一般の方向けの話ではないんです
心の騙す機能というか
self-deceiving、self-deception（自己欺瞞）という
自分で自分を騙す機能なんですね
そういうのが心にあるんです
それは一般の仏教の話では
まず言わないことになっているんです
これ、言いにくいんです
大変怖いことになっちゃうんですね
ですから
この話は仏典の中でも内緒話で
厳密に修行する方々に注意するために
ほんのわずか　一、二カ所でしか書いてないんです
だからパーリ語を読まれる方々でも見つからないと思います
一般の経典の中では明確にわかるようにはしてないんです
これは私にしても
すごく話しにくいテーマなんですね
この騙す機能というのは
一般の方々の心は混乱してしまう恐れもあります
気をつけてしゃべってはみますけど
全部まとめて今日でお話はできないと思いますけど
1 冊全部そのへん書いてますからね
私ではないんですが
ものすごい大長老が
1 冊まとめて
この騙す機能について書いている本がございまして
その本の内容を中心にお話しします
騙すことは普通ありますね
人に騙されちゃったと
それは良くないということは誰でも知ってるし
騙されないためにはどうすればいいかという話は一般的には喋れます
ずっとそういう話を私はしているんですね
あまり騙されないようにしてくださいと
でも　あまりにも騙されないように注意しちゃうと
またかえって
性格がね
悪くなってしまう可能性もあります
人の話に全く耳を傾けない わがままな人間になる可能性もあります
簡単に騙される人間というのは
人の話にすぐ乗ってしまいますからね
それも良くないし
だからといって騙されないように頑張ってしまうと
頑固な 人の話に全く耳を傾けない人間になってしまいます
中道的なところを見つけなくちゃいけないんですね
人の話も聞かなくちゃいけない
だからといって
何でも鵜呑みにしてもいけないし
その両方なんですね
ですから
自分の判断能力を使う必要もあるし
自分一人で判断能力ない場合は
知識人の話をよく聞いて
それを使用して判断してみる必要もあります
日常生活はそういうふうな生き方でなければいけません
我々はかなり弱いんです
普通の方々っていうのは
すぐ人の話に乗せられてしまいます
あるいは全く人の話は聞かないと
どちらかの極端に入ってしまってるんですね
自分で判断しなさいと言ったら
なかなかできなくなって
あるいは大変大胆な 悪い判断してしまう場合もあるし
人の話も聞きなさいと言ったら
何でも他人に
決めてもらいたい 弱い人間になる可能性もあります
やっぱり正しく生きてほしいんですけど
今日はその話ではないんです
他人に騙せないようにではなくて
この自己の騙し機能、self-deceptionという
英語の単語も誤解するかもしれませんけど
self-defense(自衛)ではないんです
自己防衛ではないんです
自分で自分をdeceive、騙すという
それはどういうことでしょうかね
私たちは人に騙されちゃうと
かなり気が立っちゃうんですよ
あの人に騙されたと
あの人に裏切られたと
あの人は約束破ったと
そういうふうに他人については
我々はきつい条件をつけちゃうんですね
人に対してはきちんと約束を守りなさいと
言うことをちゃんとしなさいと
人を騙すなよ とかね
信頼できる人間になりなさいと 他人に向かって我々は激しく言うんです
そこで騙されたところで
ものすごく落ち込んだり
あるいは気が立ったり
怒ったりはします
そういうことは一見
なんかいいんではないかなと
この社会はこんな遊びはできませんと
この社会ではしっかりと約束を守らなくてはならないんだと
商売も生きることもできなくなるんだと
正直でなければ
約束を守らなければ
決まりを守らなければ
そういうしっかりできている社会に生きているんではないか
と思いがちですけどね
でも　本当の心の状態を見てみると
自分でも自分が何者かとわからないんです
ですから
仏典から言えるのは
あなたはあなたのことを知ってますか？
あるいは簡単に人に聞いてみると
あなたはどういう性格の人間でしょうかと
自分に聞いたならば
しっかりと言えますかね
私はこのような性格の人間です
私はこういう性格ですとハッキリと言えますか
だって自分のことでしょ
これ なかなか大変だと思いますけど
あなたは何者ですか？
という質問に答えられないんです
人に聞けば
あなたは真面目な人間ですか？
あるいは いい加減な人間ですか？
努力する頑張り屋さんですか？
怠け者ですか？
いろいろ性格はありますからね
そんなふうに聞かれて答えられますかね
これすごい真剣な話なんです
あなたはどんな人間ですかと聞いたら答えられますか？
というよりは
What type of man are you?
What type of person are you?
答えられますか？
自分のパーソナリティ
人格性について
自分のことも知らないわりには
我々は堂々と人のことを言うでしょう
あの人は怠け者だ
あの人はかなり感情的だ
あの人はヒステリータイプだ
あの人は信頼できないんですよ
そうやって人の性格についてはいくらでもレッテルを貼る
人格分析とかテキストまでありますよ
あのパーソナリティのね
分析について本まで書きます
すべて他人の性格の分析なんです
あれでいいんですかね
自分が何者かともわかってないのに
自分にはあの人が頑張り屋か
あるいは怠け者か判断できますか
心の働きは簡単に判断できないんです
この前も
私はある一つのエピソードを言ったんです
あるお坊さんが私に言った話で
昔の話でね
昔と言ってもそんな昔ではなくて
あるお坊さんが田舎で
その人の友達の話でしたけどね
学校で先生をやってるんですね
学校というのは早く終わりますから
学校が終わったら
そのお坊さんがお寺に戻って
散歩していたみたいですね
村人が そのお坊さんがずっと行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり
散歩しているのを見たんですね
あるおばあさんがそれを見ていて
あのお坊さんが真面目に修行しているんだと
見ているんですね
ありがたくて
学校の仕事が終わって 帰ってから時間を無駄にしないで
瞑想しているんだと思っていて
歩きながら そのお坊さんが いきなり飛び上がったんですね
パッと 飛び上がってまだ歩いているんですね
そこで見ていたおばあさんが考えたんですね
おそらくこのお坊さんが瞑想して
うまくいって自分が悟っているか 確かめたかもしれません
空を飛べるかどうか
そう思っている人々いますよ
そんな話したら時間なくなりますからね
だったら鳥は皆悟っていることになりますけどね
それですごくありがたくなっちゃって
確かめなくちゃいけないと思って
お坊さんのところに行って挨拶して
あの先生
ちょっと飛び上がったんだけど
あれはどういうことでしょうかと聞いたら
お坊さんが
ああ　おばあちゃん
あれはね
私は歩いている時に子供の頃を思い出したんだと
子供の頃を思い出して
皆と野球やってたんだと
子どもたちと一緒に
球が体にぶつかりそうになったんです
それで飛び上がって球をよけたんだと
そういう話をしたんだそうです
そのお坊さんが妄想しながら
自分の子どもの頃をね
妄想しながら歩いてただけなんですね
でも それを見ていたおばあちゃんにとっては
それはまた違う解釈なんですね
真面目に修行しているんだと
もうそろそろ悟るでしょうと
そうやって人のことわからないんですね
おばあちゃんが聞いたのは良かったんですけど
もし聞かなかったらどうなるんですかね
あのお坊さんはすごい立派な人というふうな
もう話が進んじゃうでしょうね
ですから
人の心っていうのは
我々にとってはすごい面白い話で
球を避けただけですよと
ボールを避けただけですよということで
面白く喋ってますけどね
自分の心さえ読めないんだから
他人の心もなかなか読めない
他人の性格も言いにくいんですね
わかりにくいんです
それでよくあることは
例えば私が怒りっぽい人間か優しい人間かと聞いてもわかりません
どういうことかというと
みんな親切で
自分の気持ちに逆らうことなく仲良くしてくれるんだったら
私も親切なんですね
私はみんなと仲良くしているんです
みんな私に邪魔をする
いじめる
攻撃する
バカにする
その場合は何でしょうかね
その場合は私も攻撃を返す
あなたは親切な人ですか？
怒りっぽい人ですか？
と言ってもわからないんです
それは条件によって
その条件の中で反応するだけ
時々すごい元気そうな 力強そうな人々いるでしょう
でも何か起きたら全部
もう何もできなくなっちゃって
落ち込んじゃって
布団から立ち上がれない状態まで落ち込む時もあります
今まで元気でみんなに頑張りなさい
頑張りなさいと言ってきたのに
今は何でしょうかと聞きたくなるぐらいになっちゃいます
ですから
この我々の心っていうのは
そう簡単にわかるものじゃない
別に複雑というわけじゃないんです
ただ　その時
その時の環境に反応するだけ
いわゆる反射人間だけなんです
大したことじゃないんです
みんな赤色を着ているんだったら
私も赤色を着るぞ となるだけのことで
みんな髪の毛真っ赤に染めたならば
見る人は髪の毛真っ赤に染めている
じゃあ私も ということになるだけ
それで深い意味があります？
全然 何もないんです
人間やっていることには何も深い意味がないんです
ただ反射人間で
行動しているだけのことなんです
だから そういう人に聞いても
あなた何者ですかと わかるわけないでしょうに
ただ反射的に生きているだけなんです
心は別に複雑なものではないんです
ただ反射しているだけ
人にちょっと失礼なことを言われたら
いきなり怒りで燃え上がる
褒められたら喜んで舞い上がっちゃう
ただそれだけ
こちらがすごく丁寧に挨拶をして
丁寧な敬語でお話しすると
向こうも同じレベルで返してくれる
それで私が「この人は丁寧な 行儀の良い人だ」とメモに書いても
それは間違いであって
ただその時の反応だけなんですね
人間っていうのはそうやって
ただ反射人間なんですね
反射人間だから
私はこれから怒るか笑うか
泣くか 人を褒めるか けなすか
人を助けるか 殴るか わからないんです
どちらでもあり得るんです
今日まで何も悪いことをしなかった人が
明日とんでもない犯罪を起こす可能性はあります
悪いことばっかりやっていた人が
自分を直して立派に真面目に生きている可能性もあります
ですから
正しく仏教的な立場で言うならば
我々は人間にラベルを貼って
この人はこういう人間だよ と
確定することはやめた方が生きやすいんです
人にラベルを貼って
悪人　善人
怒りっぽい人
怠け者　頑張る人
そういうふうにラベルを貼らないほうがいいんです
ラベルを貼ったら
そのラベル自体が変化しないでしょうに
固定になるでしょうに
固定した人格がないと思ったほうが
人間関係はうまくいくんです
それは暗い話じゃないんです
人格固定していないんだから
どうということないんだから
変えようと思えば変えられるし
もっと悪くしようと思ったら悪くすることもできます
決して犯罪を起こさない
例えば子供がいるとしますね
いとも簡単に犯罪する人に育てることはできますよ
何のこともない
とても簡単です
ですから
悪い言葉で言えば
人のことを信頼しない方がよろしいし
自分のことも絶対に信頼しないほうがいいです
悪い言葉で言えばそういうことなんですけど
優しい言葉で言えば
まあ そんなに
感情的になって 舞い上がって
ああ　びっくりしたとかね
そんな必要ないんです
たとえ自分の子どもでも
店の窓ガラスを割って帰ったとしても
「なんてとんでもないことをするんだ」
「びっくりした」
そんなに混乱しなくてもいいんです
そんなことはあり得ることだからね
旦那さんがちょっと浮気しただけで
自殺したいほど混乱するでしょうに
どうということはないんです
そんなことは
旦那様はそういう性格で
奥さんも負けない性格でしょうに
ですから
固定した人格が欲しくて生きることはよくないんですね
あなた昔はすごく優しかったではないか
私のことをかわいいと言ってくれたではないか と言って
55歳になったおばちゃんが旦那さんをいじめても意味がないでしょ
結婚するときは
この人は私をすごく大事にしてくれるんだ
だから一生この人と一緒になるんだと思っても
２、３週間で大事にしないようになってしまう可能性もあるし
あるいは大事にしてくれる可能性もある
どっちかわからないんです
40年間夫婦仲良くしても
41年目で全部壊れてしまう可能性もあります
何が起きても驚かないことが智慧ある人の生き方なんですね
ああ　そう
別れたんですかと
ああ　なるほど
それで終わっちゃうんです
なぜかというと
人の性格っていうのは
その場その場でぐるぐる変わるものなんです
性格っていうのは波に例えてみたら
波っていうのは
その時どきの条件で現れるのであって
波には厳密に決まっている形がありますか？
決まっている高さ
決まっている形
決まっているリズム
そういうのはないでしょうに
その時の条件によって 波が激しくなるか
ゆっくりになるか
高くなるか 短くなるか
いろいろ
私たちの性格というのは波と同じもので
その時の条件によって反射するだけのことなんです
最初に言いたいのは
私は私のこともわからない
私の性格についても保証はない
ですから
人の性格を見て びっくりしたり
落ち込んだり
混乱したり
舞い上がったりする必要はないんだと
クールな心で 落ち着いて見てみると
うまく生きていられるんです
それは無知な 無気力な生き方じゃないんです
いわゆる理解能力はあるんです
ある人がいきなり感情的になって
すごい感情的になって怒ったりする
そうすると
なるほど
この人はこういう条件の中で
こういうふうに感情的になって怒っているんだよと
この人が怒ったら
ちょっと都合が良くないんだと
分かった人が
ちょっと環境を変えてあげる
ちょっと言葉で褒めてあげる
褒めてあげたら
今まで怒っていた人は何のことなく笑っちゃうでしょうに
何のことなく笑っちゃう
人間関係はうまくはかどれるんです
人に固定した性格を与えないならば
我々の生き方は何でしょうかね
人が一回だけでも悪いことをしたら
みんなに言いふらしちゃう
あの人こういうことをしたんだよと
1977年10月11日
3時30分こういうことをしました と
そういう一回の 出来事を覚えておいて
永久的にその人は泥棒か犯罪者か レッテルを貼ってあげるんですね
そういう生き方でしょ
ですから
直るにも直らなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば 強盗した人がいるとします
若い頃 何か訳があって強盗してしまった
それで見つかって
取り調べられたとします
私たちはその人の人生に 永久的に
この人は強盗だとレッテルを貼ってあげる
そうすると
罪を償ってから社会に戻っても
仕事を探そうかなと思ったら
裏で誰かが
この人は刑務所で3ヶ月間いて帰った人ですからね
強盗してね
気をつけてくださいと言っちゃうでしょうに
それで仕事は見つからない
そうすると
その人はまた強盗しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
生きられませんから
そうやって我々は人間に固定した人格を与えてあげて
わざと他人の生き方をそんなふうにしてしまうんですね
すごい残酷ですよ
もう一つあります
いい方向を見れば。イメージあるでしょ
特にタレントの人々の世界では
イメージを作って それで生きているんですね
イメージっていうのは
一時的な、人を面白くするためにやるだけで
例えば すごく頭の悪い人のイメージで
テレビでウケたならば
一生そのイメージでやろうとする
違うキャラクターを見せちゃうと
プロデューサー みんな 機嫌が悪いんですね
悪役をやった人が悪役で売れたならば
死ぬまで悪役をやらなくちゃいけないし
恋人役で売れた人は死ぬまでその役をやらなくちゃいけないと 決まってるんですね
それは演技の世界でね
演技の世界は実際の生活と違いますから
関係ないんですけど
それでもトラブル起きたりはします
本人が悩んだりする場合もあります
違う演技もやってみたいんだけど
なかなかやらせてもらえない
私たちはタレントではなくて
どんな人にもそうやってイメージをつけてあげる
あるいは「悪い性格」とラベルを貼ってあげる
貼ってあげて
自分がやったものだから
ずっとそのままで
その人の性格を変えられないようにと頑張っちゃうんですね
他人に対してえらい迷惑なんですね
本人に対しては
例えば 子どもに対して
あなたよく頑張りますね
頭がいいですね と言って
みんなにも言いふらしたりして
うちの子はよく勉強しますねと
よく頑張りますよと
そんなイメージを作ってあげたら
その人の人格が
壊れるんでしょ
精神的なストレスたまったりして
人間関係が壊れてしまうんですね
もし一回だけでも試験で点数取れなかったならば
お母さんが怒って
そんなふうに育てた覚えはないと
子どもはバカだから
あなたに育てられた覚えはないと 言い返せばいいんですけどね
みんな自然に育てるものですからね
母に何もできませんですけど
子どもはそこまで頭鋭くないから
うぬぼれるんですね
もったいない
申し訳ないことをしたんだと
お母さんが
100点満点取れるように私を育てたんだと
なのに 私は今日は
40点だからと
無茶でしょうね
母親にそんな
100点取れるように子供育てられますかね
ただ食べるものをあげるぐらいのことでしょうね
寝かしてあげる
食べるものをあげる
服を洗ってあげるとかね
それぐらいのことしかやってないのに
母親はびっくりする
がっかりする
なんで勉強しないんですか？
とかね それは母親が悪いんで
なぜ ああいうイメージを作ってあげたんですかと
子どもはイメージに合わせようと努力するでしょうし
でも それですごく苦しんじゃうんですね
本当のところは
誰にも 何の性格もないんです
その場その場で 反応するだけ
反応して生きているだけなんです
生命として仏教は見ているんだから
猿も犬も人間も ほとんど同じなんです
ただ その環境に応じて反応
反応して生きている
たとえカラスでも いじめてみてください
かえって人間をいじめる凶暴な鳥になる
カラスに優しくしてみてください
結構かわいい鳥になってくるんです
ものすごく頭のいい鳥で
食べ物でもあげたりしてね
ちょっと話してみてください
その人の顔と声を覚えておいて
すごく親切にしてくれるのです
一番なじみやすい鳥はカラスなんです
鳥の中で 頭がいいんですから
でも一般的には「カラスは嫌だ」とか
思ってるんだから
確実にカラスも人間に邪魔をする
攻撃をする
巣で卵を温めている時は カラスは凶暴でしょ
それはみんな失礼だから
カラスに対して
カラスの性格を書いている方々も
その時は気をつけてください
カラスはすごい凶暴ですよと
でも 私の個人的な経験で言えば
カラスが巣を作って卵を守っていても
そこらへんで 平気で遊べるんです
自分の国だったら全然気にしない
時々子どもたちが木に登ったりするでしょう
その時は知らないんだけど
上にカラスの巣があるんですね
その時も子どもを攻撃しないんです、カラスは
攻撃したら子どもが落ちて大変なことになるでしょうね
子どもは遊びで木登りしているんだと わかってるんですね
私は見ていたんだからね
カラスは何するんですかと
カラスの母親が来て
木の上に座ってキャアキャアと鳴くんですね
鳴くと 子どもはうるさいということで 降りたりします
あまりにも激しく鳴くと
もうわかります
子どもが周りを見ると
カラスの巣があるから心配しているんだと
じゃあ降りましょうと
何のことなく降りるんです
ですから
お互いに理解あるんです
そうすると攻撃はなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから
カラスは凶暴な鳥ですか？
親切な鳥ですか？
そんな決まりがないんです
カラスは人間の言葉をしゃべることを皆様ご存知でしょう
教えてあげたらすごい綺麗に発音するんです
そんなもんなんですね
動物でも 凶暴にするか 親切にするか は
我々のアプローチ次第 決まってる性格がないんです
決まってる性格がないからこそ
うまく管理できるんです
そこで我々はある間違いをするんですね
カラスは凶暴
決まってるんだ
あなた凶暴にしなさいと
特に日本の社会はすごい厳しいでしょうね
みんなにレッテルを貼ってくれるでしょう
迷惑なんですけど
自分で「私はこんな者だ」というならば
それは自由です
いいんですけど
それは認めません
私があなたは何者か決めます と
それで決めてくれちゃって
この人は怠け者だ
この人は怒りっぽい
この人は信頼できない と
そうやって決めてもらって
強引に決めてもらった性格は
私たちは守らなくちゃいけない
否応なしに
それぐらい精神的ないじめがありますかね
人間には 怒鳴りたい時は怒鳴る自由は必要でしょうし
怒りたい時は怒る自由も必要でしょうし
ふざけたい時はふざける自由も必要でしょうし
真剣真面目になりたい時は 真剣真面目になる自由も必要でしょう
だってそれは決まってる性格じゃないんだから
ある環境に行ったら ふざけたくなる
みんなそうでしょう
お祭りとかね
そういうところに行ったら
心が温かくなってきて
踊りたくなる
それでも 怒りっぽくて気が荒いと 隣からレッテル貼ってもらったならば
たとえお祭りに行ってもみんなこうやって見るんだから
そうすると楽しむことができなくなっちゃうんですね
あるいは平気で言うんですね
あなたが来たら困りますよと
そんなことないはずでしょう
どんな人でも
真面目になる時もありますし
怠け者になる時もありますし
ふざける時もありますし
真剣に頑張る時もあります
その場その場で現れる反応のみなんです
そこを理解しておけば
かなり人生として生きやすいということがあるんです
問題は かなり解決しやすい
聖書でもね
すごい厳しく言ってます
人を判断するなよと
判断すること自体 罪として書いてます
仏教はあまり人気ないのはわかりますけど
キリスト教はかなり人気あるでしょう
でもみんな平気で人を判断する
判断してはいけないと書いてますけどね
結局 私たちは私たちのことはわからない
人に聞いても
あなた いつ奥さんとケンカしますか？
聞いても わかりますかね？
次の夫婦ゲンカはいつでしょうか？
聞いてもわからないでしょうに
いくらその人を責めても
あなたでしょうに、ケンカするのは
次の夫婦ゲンカの時間を言ってくださいと
そんなこと言っても誰もわからない
その条件によって 夫婦ゲンカになるかならないか
ただそれだけのことなんです
この騙す機能というのは
そんなものでもないんです
これから騙す機能について喋りますけど
全部喋る時間はないと思いますけど
自分が自分を騙すんだから ハッキリしたことがあるんです
”自分でわからない”
自分でわかってインチキやってる場合は 騙す機能じゃないんです
わかってないことは必要な条件なんです
例えばこういう人がいますね
よく善いことをする
みんなに対して親切
でもその人知ってます
善いことをしておけば
みんなに親切に振る舞っておけば
自分の立場が安全だと
だって自分のお客さんでしょうしね
私の店で物を買ってくれるんだと
本当は私の品物はちょっと高いんだけど
それでも私のところで買ってくれるんだと
だからちょっとわがまま言われても
ものすごく親切にしてあげるんだと
そうすると
その人は 人に対しては親切
でも本人がそれは偽善であることは ちゃんと知っています
だから騙しているわけじゃないんです
本人がちゃんと計画通りにやっていることで
自分が儲かりたい
自分のお客さんが離れないようにしておきたい
そちらにあるのは「自分が儲かりたい」という気持ちだけ
じゃあ 儲かるためにどうすればいいんですか？
だったら品物を買いに来たら
ご褒美もあげましょうと
おまけもあげましょうと
一回二回ちょっと損したってもいいんじゃないかと
例えば 2000、3000円の品物を買ったら
1000円の品物を
これもあげますから持って行ってください とかね
何か余分にあげたりする
そうすると
買った人も「こんな物をくれたら
店にはprofit(利益)がないでしょう」とかね
心配したりもします
それで次から次へとその店に行く
それで損がなく
その店が得するようになるでしょうに
そうやって計画立ててやることは 騙す機能ではないんです
いわゆる偽善であることを
インチキであることを 自分でしっかりと覚悟しているならば
これではないんです
だからこれは一般の方々にはなかなか
関係ない話なんです
わかりやすく言えば
自分が偽善であることさえ 気づかないことなんです
それが自分を騙す機能なんです
そうでなきゃ騙されてないでしょうに
騙されてるっていうことは はっきり騙されてることなんです
完璧に
今日喋ろうと思う
努力しているテーマの場合は
まるっきり本人は気づかない
どう頑張っても気づけない
ですから
絶対 言ってはいけません
バレても
言っちゃうと 向こうはものすごい凶暴になって 攻撃して
私もそういう失敗したことがあります
いろいろ修行したりするでしょうに
なかなか進めないとかありますし
一所懸命 なぜ進めない
なぜ進めないということでね
こういうふうに真面目にやっていますけど
うまくいかないんだと
何かないんでしょうか
何か問題ありますかって
本当はこういうことでしょ？
言ったら「とんでもないことだ」って
なんでそんなこと言うんですかって
ものすごく怒って
失礼ではないか
それっきり 仏教までやめてしまうんですね
大変なんです
でもこちらでは知ってますけど
その性格がある限り もう進めないんだと
例えば 自分の欲を正当化するために 欲をなくす修行をする
そうすると永久的に欲はなくせないでしょ
それでやってもやっても
自分が疲れちゃうし
それで私にすごく希望するんですね
免許を出してくださいと
免許を皆伝しなさいと
こういうことでしょうと
でも それはできないし
私にはそんな権利ないんだからね
あなたは瞑想進んでるんだよ とかね
そんな権利はないんです
あなたは悟ってるんだよ とかね
すべて自己証明の世界だからね
人の心にラベルを貼る権利はまるっきりないんです
お釈迦様の教えに逆らって
そんな馬鹿なこと いくら頼まれたってやりません
自分の感想は述べますけどね
私から見れば
何々さんが真剣に 真面目に頑張ってるみたい と
なかなか進んでるみたい とか
それはあくまでも自分の感想であって
じゃああなたに免許を出しますよと
そんな権利 どこから私に
みんな平等でしょうね
だいたい 真面目に 本当に進んでる人だったら
褒めても
放っておきなさいと言うんです
褒めてもらいたくてやってるわけじゃないんだよ
修行の世界では大変なことで
言ってはいけないことなんですね
言ったらその人が崩れちゃうんですね
壊れてしまいます
なぜ人が混乱して壊れますか？
その人が悪いんですかね？
そうでもないんです
自分が完璧に騙されているんだから
理解できないだけのことなんです
そこで仏教の世界で
お坊さんたちが一人で修行しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
お釈迦様がすごく心配なんですね
悟ったつもりは とても良くないんです
煩悩なくなったつもりは とても危険なんです
その煩悩なくなったつもり
悟ったつもりを消すために
厳密に ものすごい厳しく 自分の心をチェックする方法は
徹底的に書いてあるんですね
だから その世界の中の一部なんです
この 騙す機能ということは
こういうこともあります
今は騙されてない場合もあります
でも やがて騙されるということがあるんです
すごくややこしいんです
例えば 本当に仏教はいいこと
ありがたいことで
俗世間でやっても意味がない とかね
頑張って修行してみるぞと
正直に始まる
そこまでは騙されてないんです
それでやり始めたら 途中で
騙す機能が働いてくるということがあるんです
この壁はみんなにあると思ったほうがいいんです
わかりやすい例を言います
お母さんが子どもをしつけする時あるでしょ
その時 子どもが なんでお母ちゃん そんなに怒ってるんですか？
と聞いたら
お母ちゃんの反応はなんですかね
私は怒ってないですよと
全然怒ってないんだと
あなたのために言ってるんだよと
そんなこと言わなかったら
あんた大変でしょうと
全然怒ってないと 否定するんですね
本当は怒ってるんです
自分が怒ってるか しつけしているか 区別できますか？
そこらへん
微妙なところなんですね
例えば 現代は自由な世界だと言って
教室で子どもたちは やりたい放題
自由に勉強したり
勉強しなかったり
いろいろと
そこで教師は まあいいんじゃないか
みんなそれぞれ自由で
勉強したい子は勉強する
勉強したくない子は それでいいんじゃないか と
先生は 自分が現代的で 自由に教えてるつもりでしょ
あるいは 自分が腰抜けである と
子どもに怒鳴って 勉強しろと言う勇気がない と
言えますかね
もし言ったら どうなるんですか
先生 あなたは腰抜けやと
子どもたちに怒鳴って
勉強しろよ
冗談じゃない
勉強好きであろうが嫌いだろうが関係ないんだ
勉強しなかったら ただではすみませんよ と言って
子どもに勉強させる勇気がない
腰抜けだ と言ったら
先生はすごく怒るでしょ
理屈まで言うでしょ
あんたみたいな古い考えの人の話を聞きたくない と
今の世の中はそういう教育はないんだ と
いろんなことを言うんですね
ですから
先生が落ち着いているのは
できた先生だからか
腰抜けだからか 分かりますかね
生徒を怒鳴る先生も
本当に生徒を心配して 真面目に怒鳴っているか
ただ腹が立って
嫌で やってるかと
これ区別できますかね
そこらへんなんです
自分が騙されているということ
そこを いくら騙されないようにしましょうと思っても
やがて騙されます
その次元を乗り越えなくてはならないんです
悟りという場合はね
完全に心清らかになった状態
仮定して仏教は喋ってますから
その状態に至るためには
まず 粗っぽい怒り
粗っぽい欲
やっぱり私は欲張りだと
じゃあ頑張るぞと
やっぱり私はしょっちゅう怒るんだと
じゃあ頑張るぞと言って
隠れてない
あらわになっている貪瞋痴を制御する
そうすると 今まで隠れていた貪瞋痴も出てきます
それも制御する
私はここまで欲があったんですか とかね
驚いたりしながら
そこまでいいんですね
次なんですね問題は
次に 自分がまあよくできた と
もうほとんど煩悩なんかないんだ
欲は仏教のおかげで
ほとんど欲張らなくなっちゃった
仏教のおかげで本当に怒れなくなった と
そこから危険なんです
仏教のおかげでよくなったところから
ものすごい危険なんです
そういう人々を見てください
やっていることは何なのかと
元よりひどいことをやっちゃうんです
元よりも性格の悪いこと
人を馬鹿にすることやったりする場合あるんです
本人は気づかないんです
そこからなんですね
問題は だからそうやってこの仏教のために
真理のために
欲をなくすために
解脱のために と思って貪瞋痴を使う
貪瞋痴で行動する
そういうことで もう騙されています
その壁は誰にでもあります
修行過程ではね
ちゃんと報告すると
私は一応
その対処方法というか
言わないんですけど
直す方法は言いますけど
大体そういう方々に限って 言ってくれないんですね
言ってくれないと こちらも言わないんです
なんか修行の世界
心の働きは私に隠してるなと
隠したって何の意味もない
バカバカしい
隠すってことは隠せませんだからね
人の心は全然隠せません
体は隠せます
私はいつでも言うことだからね
ドアの外から喋ったらわかりません
体は簡単に隠せます
でもドアの向こうに人がいて
しゃべっても心はわかるでしょうに
だから隠せないものを よく隠しているつもりでね
そうすると私も「全然わかってない」と
処理をして
じゃあどうぞ頑張ってくださいと
でも ずっとその調子で止まっちゃうんですね
言ってもらわない限りは
手を出すことは全く不可能
単純なんですけど
全く不可能
言っちゃうと もう全部終わり
かえって こちらに攻撃して
何やるかわからなくなっちゃうんです
だから大変単純なことなんですけど
ですから
お釈迦様はこうおっしゃっているんですね
人間というのはね
ただ正直でいればそれだけで十分だよと
偉そうな 徳を積むとかね
善行為をするとかね
そんなことはどうでもいいんですから
ただ正直でいれば 正直になる
それだけでいいんだと 人を育てられますよと
例えば あなた怒っているんだと言ったら
正直な人だったら 気づいてたら
やっぱり怒ったんですね と言うし
でも自分が認めないんだったら 正直で言うんですね
あなたが怒っていると言っても
私は認めません とか
正直ですからね
私は怒っていると認めませんと そう言った人が「いいよ」と
向こうも言ってあげるし
それで正直だから
あら 怒りと言ったんだけど
怒ってないと私は思ってはいるんだけど
本当はどうなのかと
自分のことを調べる
調べたら発見する
それで人が成長します
ですから
成長したい人に必要な道徳はたった一つ
大量の戒律を守るとかそんなことではないんです
たった 1個
正直ということ
それだけやれば すべてうまくいきます
本題に入ります
例えば 人間には欲がありますね
そんなことは誰でも知っています
欲があります
欲があると何をするかということも知っています
それで 欲が良くないと
自分ではいくらかは思っているんですね
思っていて
知らないうちにこうなっちゃうんです
自分の欲をどういうふうに正当化して育てればいいかと
本人はわからない
それでものすごく
人のことをよく面倒を見る人間になるんです
他人のこと
よく他人のために行動する
人のために
世のために頑張っちゃうんです
世のために
他人のために頑張ると
欲のある人にはできることじゃないでしょ
本人もすごくいい気持ちでいるんです
私は他の人と違って
人生を人のためにかけているんだと
でも心の中で それで自分を正当化しているんですね
自分が大変喜んで 善いことをやっているんだと
善い人間だと
他の人とは違うんだと
他を助けることによって
物質的に 自分を助けてもらうことにしちゃうんですね
自分の立場を安定化させちゃう
自分には仲間がいる
味方がいる
大丈夫です
助けてあげた人々はいくらでもいるんだから
それも一つの投資と同じ
それで欲が消えるわけじゃないんですね
そういう機能があるんです
わかりにくいと思いますけどね
例えば 人にものをあげなさいという話がありますね
人にものをあげなさいと仏教で言うのは
ものに対する自分の執着をなくすためなんです
これは自然法則で 何かものを持っちゃうと
それには執着する
それはありがたいもの
私のものだと
ものと言えば 財産も知識も ものなんです
社会的な立場も ものなんです
仏教から見れば
物質だけではないんです
精神的なものも ものなんですけど
そうやって自分のものに とらわれちゃう
嫌なものを買う人はいないでしょうに
花買っても
気持ち悪いから買いました と言う人はいないでしょうに
私が店に行って 女性の服は買わないでしょうに
なんで買ったんだい
着られないから
着られないから買う人はいないでしょう
物を買う=執着があるということは当たり前なんです
食べないものを買う必要はないでしょうに
食べられないものは買う必要はないです
食べるものを買う場合も
自分が食べるもの 食べられるもの
自分にとって欲しいものは買うでしょう
勉強するときでも同じことで
自分が好きなことを勉強するんであって
嫌なことを勉強するということはしません
人間が持っている精神的な財産も 物質的な財産も すべて欲なんですね
ですから
その ものを捨てなさいよ
あげてみなさいと言うと
単純論理で 自分が粘り強く執着している
一生大事にするぞと
それをあげてみちゃうと
自分の執着が消えちゃうんですね
執着がある場合は あげることはできないんですね
あげるためには
ものに対する執着をなくさないと
例えば人に
1000円あげたいんだけど
1000円私も欲しいんだけど
やっぱりあげたい
やっぱり私は欲しいと
自分が欲しいと思ったらあげられないんですね
まあしょうがない
欲しいんだけど
あげますよということで
その 1000円に対する執着を捨てないとあげられない
ですから
あげるということは 執着を捨てるという心理的な機能
計算してお釈迦様がおっしゃっているんです
だから あげればあげるほど
ものにとらわれない心が出てこないと 正しい布施にならないんです
ですが 逆にこういう教えがあるでしょうね
あげることは とても善いこと
豊かになるのは執着ない人なんですね
自然というのはすごい
意地悪システムなんです
ものが欲しくて
豊かになりたくて頑張っている人は不幸になっちゃうんです
ものにとらわれない人にとっては
いつでも ものが回り回っているんですね
お金が欲しいと思うとお金が逃げちゃうんですね
あってもなくてもどうでもいいやと思う人の周りは回ってるんです
そういう法則が心の法則です
ですから
このあげるということをすると
布施ということをしちゃうと
これはいいことだと
わかって
そのうわべだけを考えて どんどんあげたりします
人が来たら何かあげたりする
お土産をあげなきゃ人を帰さないとかね
そういうことする人々もいますね
でもそれで
その人は何を考えているんでしょうかというと
それで以て
違う形の執着を作っちゃうんですね
違う形の執着を作っちゃう
あの人喜んでくれたと
すごい仲良くしてくれるんだと
そうやって違う形の何かを獲得しているんです
あげることで
そのあげることで何か違うものを獲得しようとしちゃうと
結局 執着は薄くなってないんですね
だから
こういうところは すごい複雑なんです
また わかりやすいことを言いましょう
恩を知っているという
人に何かやってもらったら
それはよく覚えておかなくちゃいけない
それは仏教では大変な素晴らしいことだと
人が自分のために何かやってくれたら
それだけは一生忘れないでくださいと
人の恩は
人の恩を忘れないことは素晴らしい性格なんです
一番恩深いのは両親なんです
人間にとっては
両親がやってくれる量っていうのは
もう誰もやってくれません
ですから
自分にとって一番恩があるのは両親でしょう
それはわかって
じゃあ一所懸命親の面倒を見ましょうと
両親の面倒を見ましょう
そうやって一所懸命
恩返しする人間になる
本当はこの恩返しするんだけど
親の面倒は見る
目上の人々の面倒を見る
それで一所懸命恩返しをする
恩返しをするんだけど
そこらへんで騙し機能があるんです
どういう騙し機能かというと
結局 恩返しじゃないんです
自分が親の面倒を見ることで大変喜んでいるんです
大変満足しているんです
みんな褒めるし
他の兄弟も すごく自分を褒めるし
両親も さんざん自分のことを褒めるし
喜んでいるし
だから両親
親戚 周りの人々
社会の人々
みんな喜ばせて
みんなに褒めてもらって
かなり得をしているんです
だから本人が知らず知らず
恩返しすることから 必然的に得られる得に 引っかかっているんです
引っかかって恩返しをするんだけど
それでどうなっているかというと
欲が本人を騙しているんです
本人は欲があるとわからない
本人に聞けば
いえ 私は別に何のことなく
親が喜んでいるから
親孝行しているだけですよと
兄弟は忙しいから
兄弟に頼んでも意味がないし
私が自分でやってますよと
それだけのことと本人が思ってますけど
裏で 恩返しすることから得られる得で 自分が溺れてるんです
ですから
欲をなくすという機能が働かなくなっちゃうんです
具体的には恩返しの行動をしています
わかりやすく言えば
親孝行したい したくないっていう気持ちじゃなくて
親孝行したら親が喜んでくれるんだと
親が喜んでくれるんだからやってますよという気持ちなんです
そうすると
あまり正直な気持ちじゃないでしょうね
親が思ってくれるんだから
親が落ち着いてくれるんだから
文句言わないんだから 恩返しをする
親孝行する
結局は 本物の親孝行じゃないんですね
いわゆる偽善的な親孝行なんですね
偽善だと自分でわかっちゃったら
騙し機能じゃないんです
自分でも偽善だとわかってないところは偽善
本当の騙し機能なんです
またもう一つ良い性格がありますね
人の話を聞く
目上の人の言うことを聞く
特に子どもの場合は
両親の話をよく聞くこと
先生の話をよく聞くことは
大変大事なことなんです
従うという意味でもないんだけど
なんか似てますけどね
必ず従うという意味ではないんですけど
話をよく聞く
言われたことはちゃんとやる
一人で朝起きなさいと言われたら
はい わかりました
今日から一人で起きます と言って
真面目に頑張る
それは子どもにしても
大人にしても
大変大事な
良い性格なんです
子どもの例で分かりやすいと思います
子どもが親に言われて
今日から自分で起きなさいよと
子どもが はい わかりましたと言って
目覚まし時計を持っていって
ちゃんと時間を合わせて
自分で寝て
朝ちゃんと自分一人で起きると
子どもが一人でやっちゃうと
ちゃんと言うことを聞く子でしょうに
それ決して悪いことじゃないでしょうに
でも そちらには裏があるんですね
そうやって人が言うことをよくやると
子どもが親が言ったこと
一人で起きましょうと言ったら
それ一人でやると 親がものすごく喜ぶんですね
なんていい子ですかと
そういうところがあるんですね
それで大人になっても
みんなそうやって よく人の話を聞く
仕事を頼まれたら しっかりとやってあげる
言われたとおりにやってあげたと言って
メリットを思う存分いただく
ですから
結局 人の話をちゃんとやることに
重点を置いているんじゃないんです
本人が無意識的に このメリットに
重点を置いているんです
騙し機能というのは
自分の性格は何ですかと
私は人の話をよく聞く
人が何か頼んだら ちゃんとやってあげる
親が何か言ったら ちゃんとする
そういう性格だと
でも本人はわからない
メリットに重点を置いているんだと
だからそこらへん また騙し機能なんです
バラしてあげることはできます
決してやってはいけないんですけどね
まあ はっきり言うことですよ
それはあんたバカだからでしょ
逆らえないんだからね
人の言うこと聞くでしょうと
あるいは褒めてくれるんだから
いい気になりたいから やっていることでしょうに
そんなこと誰も気にしませんよ と言ったら
本人が必ず怒るはずなんです
本人がショックを受けちゃうんです
あるいは
親が言うとおりにやったって どうってことはないんだと
親が褒めてあげなかったならば
ものすごく学習するんです
まあ それでわかるんですね
これは偽善行為だと
もし親がね
あんた一人で朝起きたからといって
褒めるわけにはいきませんよ
誰がそんなことで褒めるんですかと
言って 子どもが怒っちゃったならば
子どもは褒めてもらうというメリットを狙っているんですね
そういうメリットを狙っていないならば
褒められるか褒められないかということじゃなくて
正しいことを自分でやるという
まあ子どもにはそれは無理ですけど
大人にはできることでね
でも大人も結局はそういうことなんですね
メリットを狙う
狙って良いことをする
そうすると欲はなくならないんですね
これは仏教の人々のために書いているものだから
出家の修行者のために書いているんだから
リストはいっぱいありますけど
ほとんど皆様に関係ない話ばっかりなんですけど
ちょっと関係あるかもしれない
世の中で宗教に興味ある人がいるんですね
よくいます
宗教に興味がある
あれ 素晴らしい人間ですかね
あれで素晴らしい人間だと
ちょっと言い切れません
騙されている可能性もあります
どういうことかというと
世の中で金のことばかり考えている人よりは
もっと精神的なこと
心に関係あるものについて興味ある人々を褒めるんですね
尊敬するんです
世の中で
日本の社会ではいまだに
フランシスコ・ザビエルですか
キリスト教を教えた人 いまだに立派な聖人として褒めているでしょうに
なぜかというと
その人がすごい精神的な
イエズス会の神父さんでしたけどね
私は 褒めるべき人かどうかわかりませんけど
アジアの方で 聖人として強引に作り立てた人なんですけど
歴史を言っちゃうとよくないから
それはやめますけど
我々に教えられている世界から見ると
献身的で
何も持たないで
イエズス会(Jesuit)だから
貧しい生活をしながら教えてあげると
すごい精神的な人々でしょ
そうすると一般の人々は
宗教は素晴らしいと思っちゃうんですね
ですから
世の中で宗教家が褒められている
精神的な世界を目指している人々をみんな褒めている
尊敬している
なるほど
この道がいいんだと思って
自分も金儲けることではなくて
精神的な世界が好きですよと言って
精神世界にチャレンジする
でも結局 精神世界にチャレンジするのは
精神の法を発見するためじゃないんです
本人わかってないんです
ただ世の中で褒められているからなんです
ですから それも欲なんですね
善人になりたいとかね
思って頑張っちゃうんです
だからどうしようもないんですけども
悪いともいいとも何も言えないんだけど
かなり複雑なんですけど
微妙なところで自分が欲を正当化しているんですね
ですから
そういう人々は悟れないということを 僕らは言いたいだけなんです
例えば お釈迦様がサーリプッタ尊者のことをものすごく褒めているんです
弟子の中で
そこで ある出家者が
自分もサーリプッタ尊者のような生活をしようと思って
とことん仏教を勉強したり
サーリプッタ尊者のように徹底的に謙虚な生き方をしたりとかね
ものすごい謙虚に生きているとかはあり得るんです
自分のモデルはサーリプッタ大尊者だよと
そこまでは悪くはないんだけど
なんでサーリプッタ尊者に惹かれたんですかね
お釈迦様さえ褒めた人だ と
私もそのような人間にならなくちゃいけない と
いけないんだ と思ったところで欲があるんですよ
そのかすかな欲が引っ掛けになって 解脱を妨げちゃうんですね
ですから
これは精神世界の 優れている人にしか理解できない話なんです
今日しゃべっているのは
一般の人にとっては
そんなことでも頑張ってほしいんです
いろいろモデルを作って
あの人のように頑張るぞ
この人のように頑張るぞという状態から始めなくちゃいけないんです
でも進んだところで
その欲も捨てないと
それは欲のことで
それから 性的な欲がありますね
今言ったのは普通の欲のことで
悟らない限りは
性的な興味は体の中に残ってるんです
残ってるんだけど
戒律で禁じられてるでしょうね
だから誰もそれをやろうとはしないんです
体の中には残ってます
ですから
そのところでもいろいろ
騙し機能が働く場合あるんです
性的な欲は良くないんですよ
良くないんだけど
mettā(メッター)、慈しみは良くないとは お釈迦様おっしゃってないんです
それはいいことなんです
慈しみは別に
mettā (メッター)、maitrī (マイトリー)、友情だから
そこで出家者は
可愛い異性の方々を見ると
お釈迦様は慈しみで接しなければいけないと言ったんだから
すごい優しい言葉をかける
喋る 優しくしてあげる
そしたら なぜ人に優しいんですか？
人に優しくするのは当たり前だから
本人わかってないのは
この人の美しさに自分が惹かれていることなんです
微妙なところで
例えば みんなすごい可愛い人々で
自分もすごい気持ちよく
優しい気持ちで
mettā で 友情で 慈しみで接する
本人にとっては慈しみの行動なんですけど
裏で異性に対する欲は働いちゃう
別に戒律を犯すとか するわけじゃない
そこまではいかないんです
ただ親切にするだけなんです
そこらへんも
修行者がすごく気をつけなくちゃいけないところなんです
皆様の世界では そこまではないんだからね
皆様の世界でも人に優しくしますよと言ったら
だいたい可愛い人に優しいでしょ
可愛くない人には あまり優しくないというか
無視するとか 蹴飛ばしちゃうとかね
ありますから
人に優しくするのは認めます
実行もしていますよと言っても
それは可愛い人に限る
ということに気がつかない
そこらへんは騙し機能なんです
それからmettā の次、 karuṇā(カルナー)あるでしょ
カルナーっていうのは抜苦(ばっく)ですね
人を助けてあげること
人を助けてあげることも
仏教では大変良いことなんですね
皆さんはそれを認めるでしょ
人を助けてあげなきゃいけないでしょ
自分も人を助けてあげますよと言って やるんだけど
やっぱりまた可愛い人だけ助けてあげる
助けてあげる場合は
女性の方に先に手が行く
おじいちゃんが「私も助けて」と言っても
忙しいんだから
おじいちゃんは一人で頑張ってくださいと
おじいちゃんに見えるでしょ
私はこの人を助けているところだからと
本物のカルナー は 悩んでいる人を助けることなんです
男か女か調べることじゃないんです
たとえ美人がそこらへんにいても
体が泥にまみれて
そこはいいんです
泥沼に落ちてる人を助けなくちゃいけないんです
騙されている人は
泥沼に何人かが落ちて
もがいていても
泥にまみれてる人を洗ってあげるんですね
なぜかというと
可愛いんだから
服も汚れて
しょうがないでしょう とか
先に自分の手が可愛い方向に行ってしまうんですね
だから人を助ける場合も
みんな欲があるんですよ
気持ちのいい人を選ぶ
自分に気に入っている国を選ぶ
外国に行って援助するときでも
自分を褒めてくれる国を選ぶ
というふうなことになっちゃうんです
それも欲が人を騙しているところなんです
もう一つ
人間は平等でしょうと言うでしょ
言うだけで 誰もそれ認めてないんです
実際 私は世界一だと普通思っている
次に私の家族は一番いいと思っている
次に 私の村やらね
そうやって広げて
例えば 自分の民族
日本の方々だったら日本人
日本人は世界で一番いいと
というのは普通なんです
そう思うことが
平等だというのは ただ嘘で
ただ口先で言ってるだけで
いくら平等だと唇を動かして言っても
人間というのは私が一番偉いと思っているし
どんどん広げて見たとしても
やっぱり 私の家族
私の仲間
私の国 私の民族となるんです
もっと広く見ちゃうと
私の宗教の世界 ということにもなっちゃうんです
だからキリスト教の方々もみんな人間平等と言うんだけど
やっぱりそれでもキリスト教を信仰している人々が偉い
という立場は消えません
だから 人間の平等という概念はあくまでも偽善的でインチキなんです
そこで具体的な 粗っぽい例でいうと
日本は現代社会だからとかね
情報化 国際社会だから
私はそういうふうに子どもを育てていますよと
国際社会に合うように育てていますよと言って威張ってるんですが
自分の娘が黒人と仲良くすると
仲良くなっちゃって
とにかく結婚するんだと言って家に連れてきたら
親が何言うんですかね
今まで語った平等の考え方も
今まで喋っていた国際的な思考も全部飛んじゃうんです
やめなさい
あんた日本人がいないんですかと
大変なことになるんです
そこで娘さんがこう言うんです
お母さん何言うんだよ
みんな人間同じだよと言っていたでしょうに
私の気に入った人と結婚して何が悪いんですか？と
娘さんも反論する
それで私が言いたいのはこういうこと
お母さんはいいんです
娘さんは人間平等と思ってます？
じゃないんです
ただ 自分が気に入ったんだから
その人と結婚したいから
平等論を喋ってるだけで
その人のことを忘れられないから平等論を喋るんであって
本当は平等な人じゃないんです
ですから
自分の都合が良ければ人間平等だと上下関係ないんだという
都合が悪くなっちゃうと
それは認める
そういうふうに心は騙されてしまうんですね
どんな国でもよくあることで
本当は外国や他の民族のことは馬鹿にしている
心の中では馬鹿にしているんだけど
人を個人的に見たら あまりにも可愛くて
あまりにも立派で
その時いきなり国際化になっちゃうんですね
やっぱり人間国際的でなければいけませんとかね
そういうふうに心は騙してしまう機能があるんです
複雑ですけどね
難しいんです
たくさんリストありますけど
わかりやすいところだけ選んで喋ります
ケチっていうのは良くないでしょ
気持ち悪いんですね
ケチっていうことは
自分でも思っちゃうんですね
ケチは気持ち悪いんだと
思っちゃうから ケチにはなりたくないんですね
でも本当はケチなんです
ケチなんですけど
気持ち悪いから認めたくない
そうするとこの騙し機能が働くんです
どうやって働くんですか？
節約するんです
ケチじゃないんです
それで節約のプロになるんです
何でも節約と
ゴミは宝物だと言って
かなりノウハウ
テクニックまであって
人に指導するところにまで進んじゃうんです
どんなゴミでも どのように使えばいいかわかる
店で買うものはほとんどなくなっちゃうとかね
服でもボロになっちゃったら
こういうふうに使います
それは使えなくなっちゃったら
こういうふうに使いますよと
やがてこんなゴミになったら
それは肥料として使いますよと
服は また違う服にするとかね
まあ雑巾に使うとかあるでしょうね
雑巾もやがてボロボロになって使えなくなっちゃうでしょうね
そうすると土と一緒に混ぜて
肥料に使いますよと
そうやって考えてみればね
厳密にプロ中のプロでしょ
節約の 本当はケチなんです
だからケチであることは
そうやって節約という一言葉できれいに騙されちゃうんです
だからと言って節約が悪いわけじゃないんです
ケチが悪いんです
我々にそのノウハウがありますかね
これが節約であって
ケチではありませんと
その区別できますかね
その区別できたならば大丈夫ですけど
区別できないんだから
心は汚れたままで終わっちゃうんですね
贅沢に溺れることもあまりよくないでしょ
食べたい放題食べて
飲みたい放題飲んで
遊びたい放題遊んで
溺れる生活は良くないんですね
良くないと誰でも知ってます
その場合は太っ腹になるんです
私なんか太っ腹だからね
食べましょう
食べましょうとか言って
何でも使いたい放題使う
そういう人生にしてしまっちゃうんです
本人は優しくて太っ腹で
みんなにも分けてあげているつもりなんですけど
心の中はね
騙されてるんです
いろんな楽しみに溺れたいんですね
欲に溺れることが「太っ腹」という 格好いい言葉で騙されちゃう
そこらへん わかりやすいところなんです
ケチが他の方法で騙される時もあります
自分が貯金ばかりしたい
何にも使いたくないという悪い性格を持っていると
それで仏教を聞くと
仏教で言うんですね
多欲は良くないんだと
少欲知足は善行為なんです
欲は少なく
自分が得たもので満足する
収入は月々
50万円のマンションでも住めるような
収入なんですけど
一人でなぜこんなに大きなマンションに住む必要あるのか
木造アパートで十分でしょ
地震にも対応するし
鉄筋コンクリートなんか信頼できませんからね
それで 2万円払って
普通の木造アパートで 一人で生活する
すごく満足しているんだと
ああいう生き方っていうのは
少欲知足じゃないんです
お金使いたくないんですね
お金を使いたくない
ケチだということは
自分でも認めたくない
自分でも気持ち悪いんです
ですから
少欲知足という一言葉で
ペンキ塗って置いておくんですね
だからその人にはっきりと あなたはケチなだけですよと言っちゃうと
その人は必ず怒鳴るんです
必ず怒るんです
何言うんですか？
あんた方は何考えてるんですか？
私はこういうふうに
こういうふうに
こういうふうに考えて
この木造アパートに住んでるんだよと
こんな大きな
50 万ぐらい家賃を払うマンションだったら
光熱費はどれぐらいかかるとあんた思ってますかと
私にお金を払えるとしても
それは自然破壊ではないか とかね
これぐらいの家っていうのは
4人家族とかで
住んだ方がいいでしょう とかね
そういう人々に住める場所もなくなって
私にお金あるんだからといって
そんな大きなところなんて 何考えてるんですか？
だから私はこういうふうにしているんだよと
えらい説教をします
そうやって説教なんか返ってくると
もうわかっているもので
これはもうペンキ塗りなんですね
この騙し機能なんです
それからまた 仏教では一つ善行為があります
私と違って
しゃべる場合は
できるだけ
少ない言葉で喋ってくださいと
あまり喋りすぎは良くないんだと
本当は喋らないほうがいいんです
喋るとあまりにも心が混乱する
感情が乱れる
相手が理解しないと自分が混乱する
途中で何を喋っているかもわからなくなっちゃう
思ってなかったことも言ってしまう
思ってはいなかったんだけど
言ってしまったら もう終わりだからね
そういう危険があるんだから
お釈迦様は喋る時はちゃんと計量で測ってみて
これぐらい喋りますよと
20 CCぐらい喋りますよ とかね
20 CC 喋ればいいところで
6000リットルぐらい喋ってしまいますからね
時々言葉が少ない人がいますね
本人が あまり喋らない人間だと自分に言い聞かせちゃうんです
私は喋りすぎは嫌い
用がなければ私は喋りたくない
そういう人間だと
かっこよさそうに聞こえるでしょ
私は余計な言葉を喋りません
必要なことしか喋りません
それも用がなければ喋りません
だから私は言葉少ない人間ですと言ったら
なかなか立派な できた人だなと思われます
思われますけど
よく調べると
周りの人々とこの人 機嫌が悪いんです
嫌な人だから喋りたくないんです
喋りたくないことをmitabhāṇī (ミタバーニー)という仏教の専門用語でごまかしちゃう
これ mitabhāṇī (ミタバーニー)というんですけど
日本訳はわかりません
言葉をlimited、コントロールして喋るという
言葉少ないということなんですね
そういう善行為をしているんだと
例えば 医者と患者の場合でも
患者さんがあまりかわいくないし
うるさいしね
そうすると医者が言葉少ない
なんでどこですか？
何ですかね問題は？ 咳もあります？ ハイハイ
服を脱いでください
横になってください
はい この治療
この薬飲んでください
それで終わっちゃうんです
相手がかわいい女の人だったら
この頃なんか流行ってるみたいですね とか
こんな感じの病気…… よくしゃべるんだから その場合は
じゃあまた来てね とか
医者のところにまた来てっていうのはとんでもない話なんですけど
平気で言うんですよ
また来てねという医者のところに絶対行ってはいけません
その同じ医者は
おじいちゃん おばあちゃんが来たら すごく機嫌悪く
ほとんどしゃべらない
厳密に病気だけ
そうですか
咳もあります
はい わかりました
じゃあこれ持っていって飲んでください
ですから
言葉が少ないだけで格好いいわけじゃなくて
自分が話したくない相手には
言葉が出てこない
出てこないことが
この善行為として
自分は言葉が少ない人間ということにしてしまうんですね
こういう性格があります
人をけなすという
他人のことを褒めたくない
とにかくケチをつけちゃえ
つけるという性格
大体あるんですね
そんなもの普通ですよ
誰にでも
他人に対してはケチつけたいんですね
自分のことだったら
とことん膨らませて評価したいんですけど
でもそんなことを人に言っちゃうと
とんでもないことになるんですね
そうすると
我々の心の中でこの騙す機能が働くんです
人のことをケチつけてるわけじゃなくて
悪いことをする人間が嫌ですよと
世の中で誰でも悪いことしてるんだから
ただそれが嫌なだけですよ
と言って 一所懸命ケチをつけちゃうんです
あの人どうですかね
立派だとみんな思ってるんだけど
でもこういう性格の人ですよ
それがなければ とんでもなくいい人ですよ とかね
そうやって
自分がただ悪を嫌いだと
不正的なことを嫌い
ただそれだけですよと言いながら
他人にケチをつけるということをやっちゃうんです
それもいくらかわかりやすい例だと思いますけど
それから行儀があること
ちゃんと礼をすること
他人に対して素晴らしいことでしょう
挨拶することとかね
それは素晴らしいことです
相手がすごく強い 立場がある
人気がある
会社の社長
あるいは政治的な権力を持っている
あるいは凶暴な人
ヤクザとか怖い人
そういう人だったら
必ず先に挨拶をする
必ず礼をする
必ず行儀よく振る舞う
そういうことで自分が錯覚するんですね
自分がものすごくできている人間だと
相手に対して礼をする
自分から進んで挨拶をする
というふうなことを自分に言い聞かせているんだけど
本当は礼をした方が得するんだと
自分の身の安全だというところを考えているんですね
例えば乱暴な人にしても
すぐ挨拶をして喋った方が自分の身の安全でしょうね
そこは認めないで
私は人に礼をする人間だと 自分で思ってしまうんですね
思ってしまって
こういう行動をしちゃうんですね
100 以上リストはありますけど
例えば 出家だから在家の人々に説法しなきゃいけないんだと
それで一所懸命説法する
それは修行の一部だと思ったりする
出家だから真面目に出家生活をしなくちゃいけない
出家だから説法しなくちゃいけないと
言って説法する
もしかすると
その人の心の中で
人気者になりたいという気持ちが隠れている可能性はいくらでもあります
上手に喋る人を社会は褒めるんだからね
あのお坊さんはよく説法してくれて
本当に役に立ちますよと
立派な人が褒めるんだから
それは狙って説法している可能性もあります
ですから
ただ説法している説法師ですよ
説法好きですよと言っただけで
立派なお坊さんだと言えないんです
心の中がわからない限りは
ですから
出家はそこらへんも気をつける
もう私はやっぱり説法したい
私は説法したいという
そういう気持ちは良くないんですね
なんでしたいんですかと
人は聞きたくないんだから
その場合は聞きたくないのに喋るということで
やっぱり自分の立場が出てくる
自分の生きる道がそれで出てくる
みんなに認めてもらうというメリットがあるんですね
そのメリットを目指していると
それも一つの騙される行為なんですね
それから人間の悪い性格がありまして
ものすごい
喋る 喋りすぎ
喋るわ喋るわ……
どうしても止まらない
そういう性格の人々いますね
よく喋る
それは仏教で禁止しているんです
良くない性格だと
それが知っているんでしょうし
それでも精神的には 朝から晩まで喋りたいという苛立ちがあるんですね
いるでしょ
時々ぬいぐるみにまで喋るんだから
生きている人に喋って
それで気が済まない
ぬいぐるみにまで喋る
一人でも喋る
どちらにいても
いつでもその人の声だけは聞こえ続ける
このすごい喋りすぎ
これは余計な話なんですけど
ものすごい喋りたくてたまらないという人にとって
私はすごいイジメをするんです
どういうイジメかというと
よく聞いてあげる
よく聞いてあげると
その人々はすごく混乱するんです
だって喋りたいでしょうに
聞いてあげたら一番機嫌が良くなるはずでしょうに
逆なんですね
よく聞いてあげると
ものすごいおかしい結果になるんです
なぜかというと
私の聞いてあげることっていうのは
相槌
それはしないんです
ああ そうですか
ああ なるほど
それはその通りですね とか
あんな言葉は使わない
じっと聞いてる
そこでしゃべれなくなっちゃうんです
それで向こうは怒って
だってそうでしょ？
と 私に聞くんです
だってそうでしょう と
それは私に聞いても
そちらがおっしゃった言葉でしょ
だから それがそうかそうでないかは
私に関係ないんですけどと
そうすると
ものすごいパニック状態になっちゃって
しゃべれなくなっちゃうんですね
で 終わったら
用がなかったら私は「電話切りますよ」で 電話切ります
もう二度とかけてこない
かなり便利なんです
だからそこは心の働きなんですけど
しゃべる好きなんですけど
ただ内容は持ってない
しゃべりたい話題持ってない
しゃべる手段持ってない
たとえば話題があって
コミュニケーションしなくちゃいけないことがあるんだったら
こういうことを報告しなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう人の言葉には重みがあるんです
今日電話したのは
報告したいことがございます と
そうするとこちらも何でしょうかと
言葉に重みがあるんですね
そうすると会話は成り立つんであって
ポイントが終わったらお互いさま
ではさようならと 終わっちゃうでしょうに
ただ 病気でしゃべりすぎた人は
いくらしゃべっても終わらないんです
それで相手が
そうですね
そういえばそうですね とか
言い続けなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでみんな騙されちゃって
そうですね
ああ そうですね
そればっかり言ってるでしょうに
それで何時間でも無駄になっちゃうんです
だから相槌をパッとやめてみたら
本当にポイントをしゃべってる人だったら
それでもしゃべるんです
ポイントない人は いきなり混乱しちゃうんです
まあ それは置いておいて
病気でしゃべりすぎの人が
しゃべりすぎという病気の人が出家したならば できないでしょ
しゃべることは
禁止しているんだから
世間話はお釈迦様が禁止しているんだけど
説法しなさいと命令しているんですね
だったら説法にするぞ と
それで出家してから
あることないこと 説法の形でしゃべる
それは同じ病気が現れただけなんですね
それも本人が自分を騙してるんです
ただ説法してるだけですよ
ただの喋りすぎではないんだ と
それから 世間に合わせるということがあるでしょ
世の中の常識に
人々の道徳には
人間は合わせなくちゃいけない
それは仏教でも決まってます
法律は守らなくちゃいけない
その国のしきたり
習慣というのは破ってはいけないと
それから
民族ごとにいろんなことをやってますからね
日本人は日本人なりに変なことをやっているし
中国人は中国人なりに変なこと
くだらんことをやっているし
そうやってどんな民族も
くだらないことをやってます
でもその民族は 自分のやっていることをくだらないと思ってないんです
たとえば中国ではお正月 ２月になると
爆竹を1000万ぐらいやったり
ドラで音を出したり
太鼓を叩いたり
もう骨まで響くんですね
あの音に
何やってるんですかとこっちは聞きたいんだけど
やっぱり中国人がすごい気持ちよく
お正月だからやってます
静かに生活したい人間にとっては面白くないんですけど
日本にしても
すごい紳士な国だというんだけど
ほとんど褌だけでお祭りやってるでしょうに
みんなの前でなんであんなみっともないことをしますかと
我々外人が思っても
日本人にとってはそんなことじゃないしね
そうやって僕らの場合も
日本人から見ればいろいろ言われるものはあるんです
言わないんですけど
皆さんは発見しないと
ですから
どんな民族にしても
民族性というものはあります
お釈迦様はそれは壊すなよと
壊しちゃったら その人々困るでしょうに
それは仏教の決まりなんですね
だから中国人のお正月の仕来りは壊せません
どうぞやってください と
その人々
それがなくなっちゃったら
ものすごく寂しくなっちゃうんですね
日本の方々も同じことで
現代の思考で言うと
くだらんと言っても
やっぱりその日にちになってくると
お祭りがないとすごい不安を感じちゃうでしょうに
ですから
人間のしきたり 文化を壊さないことは
仏教文化人として立派なことなんです
そこで騙される機能があるんですね
時々いるんです
自分には自信がない
あるいは 人をおだてて身の安全を図りたい
そういう人々はいるんです
出家した人々の中に
自分から見れば
このやっていることは悪い
例えば日本の方々は酒を飲んでいるでしょうに 99%
それで私が来てみたら
みんな酒飲んでいる
みんなの機嫌を取らなきゃ
私は日本で生活できない
助けてくれない
だったら
それは日本の文化で みんな酒飲むんだからいいんじゃないかと言って
私はそれを褒めてあげる
褒めてあげることで
やっぱりお釈迦様は各文化の
しきたり
決まりは守りなさい
守るように言ってるんだから
私は正しいことをしていますよと威張っちゃうんです
でも本当は 心の中で「酒は悪い」と言っちゃうとまずいんですね
自分の立場が
自分の立場がまずくなるから それを言わないことにする
言わないことにして
そこをまた騙し機能で
それは文化を守ることだと
そうやって 文化を守ることだと思って
ブッダの教えを誹謗する
ということを お坊さんたちがやる場合があります
それは単なる騙し機能だと
あなたは文化を守っているのではなくて
道徳誹謗しているだけですよと
ブッダの教えを誹謗しているだけですよと
自分にご飯くれるんだから
信者さんが
その人々がやっていることを悪いと 堂々と言えないんだと
悪いと言ったらご飯くれないからと言って
あんた困りますよと
そういう性格になっちゃうんですね
それも一つの騙し
皆様に関係ないんだけど
出家には大変な関係あることなんです
良い顔をして 良いことをしているつもりですが
心の中で密かに隠れて
悪い気持ちが機能する
そこに本人が気づかない
それがポイントなんです
本人は良いことをしているつもり
その機能を騙し機能というんです
私が良いことだと思ってやっているんだ
いえ そうじゃなくて
はっきりと 良いことをしているんだと思うなんですね
でも 調べてみるとそうでもない
特に怒りがね
人助けのように表れる可能性あるし
欲が人のことをよく心配する行為として表れる可能性がある
例えばこういうこと
人にお金をあげなくちゃいけないんですね
本当はあげたくない
ただ欲なんです
それは隠すんです
本人がわからないと こう言うんですね
お金をあげると言っても
いきなりあげちゃうと
それは良くないんだ と
あなた方はちゃんとお金の管理できますか？
ちゃんとした計画がありますか？
このお金が入ったら あなた方悪くならないでしょうか？
あなた方にお金をあげるべきかどうか
そこら辺もちゃんと調べなきゃね
なんでいきなりそんなふうにお金を要求するんですか
自分のことを自分で決めるのが一番正しいでしょう とか
いちいち喋るんですね
説法する
頭で考える
寄付してくださいと言った途端
はいはい わかりました と寄付しちゃうと とんでもないことになるんだよ
だから寄付してくださいと言っただけでは寄付しません
とことん説得して
とことん情報を出してくれなきゃ
計画書やら 何から何まで出してくれなきゃ出せませんと言って
すごく相手を心配しているように見えるんだけど
結果としてはあげないぐらいのことでしょうね
だから 本当に社会のために行動する人々が募金活動に行ったら
そうやって説教するでしょ
何もこの人はくれません
はい　隣の家に行きますよと
それだけのことなんですけど
でも本人が ただケチってあげなかったということは知らないんです
ですから
あげたならばあげたで
私も人にいろんなお金をあげたと言われたことありますね
あれも知ってる
これも知ってると ふりをしているんだけど
あの人々はインチキでしょ
騙されたのではないかと言われたことがあるんですね
私もこう言うんですね
あなたよりは 私はあの連中はインチキだと知ってますよと
見ただけでも
喋り方でもなくても
どんな人間か知ってますよと
だったら なぜあげたんですかと
それをあげたの
私の個人的な行為ですよと
私がその人々にお金をあげたのは
その人々が普通に生活できるならば
普通に生活しますよと
でも普通に生活することもできない
仕事をしたくても ない
だからボランティアやってるんだとかね
たとえば地球にない国の名前を言って
なんとか国に援助しているんですよとか
なんとか言って
最近までベトナムのためにお金集めていたんだから
私はあげるんです
このお金がベトナムに行くか行かないか
私はどうでもいいんです
知ってるのは
その人々がそれでご飯食べていてもいいんじゃないんですかね
そう言っても
あまり理解してくれなかったんだけど
ですから
相手がインチキかどうか
詐欺かどうか
調べに調べた上であげますよと言うと
結局はあげないということなんですね
あげないということは
自分が欲があるということなんですね
だから仏教で見ているのは
心の欲をなくす
なくすかなくさないかという話だから
相手のことじゃない
自分がお金を人にあげたら
その人はそのインチキであろうが
詐欺であろうが
そのお金で幸せでいるでしょうに
それでいいんじゃないですか
それだけで別に
調べる必要はないし
あとで後悔する必要もないし
騙されたとかね
だったら最初から この人言ってることは嘘だと
それでもお金がないから来たんだから いくらかあげますと
それわかると
私の個人的なやり方は
まず相手に説明は断る
向こう側がいろいろ資料を持ってきて
またしゃべるでしょ
説得力ある喋り
私は「いい、喋らないでください」
そう言われても
これはいいですよ
それは私は読みませんから
用だけ言ってください
なんで来たんですか？
来たのは私たちはこう……
ちょっと待ってください
言わないでくださいと
言ったでしょ
もうとっくに知ってる
これは詐欺だと
ですから
あなた何のために来たんですか？
向こうは頭に出てこなくて
結局あなたお金欲しくて来たでしょうし
募金しなさいと
そうですけど
ではどれぐらいあげれば
あなた方はどれぐらい希望していますか？
一軒当たり
答えられなきゃいけないでしょうね、向こうは
私は資料は見てない
写真は見てない
何も見てない
説明もさせてない
一軒当たりどれぐらい考えているんですか？
と言うと
だいたい日本円で言えば
まあ 1000円ぐらいとか
はい わかりました
で  3000円あげる
じゃあ持ってきてください
それで また もういいや話は 帰ってくださいと
だから別に もともと詐欺であることは知っているし
詐欺であろうがなかろうがどうでもいいことで
お金もらって
それで食べて
なんとか幸せになるでしょうに
だから自分にとってはお金あげる機会ができただけ
周りにいる連中には しょっちゅうあげてるんだから
それで欲が消えるということはないでしょうに
あげてもキリがない
もっと欲しいとかかってくるし
ああいうふうに来る人は 一回来たら二度と来ないし
ですから
そのチャンスは生かすと
そういうふうにあげるんだったらいいんですけど
普通はそうじゃなくて
なぜこの組織に寄付しなくちゃいけないんですか？ とか
あなた方はちゃんとNPOとして登録しているんでしょうか とかね
年間のちゃんとした
出費やら
そういうレポートをちゃんと作っているんでしょうかとか
今までのどういう活動をしているんでしょうかとかね
それ調べて 調べて
さんざんいじめて
どうにもならない場合は
じゃあ 500円あげますよということになるでしょうね
だから まともな組織だったら
500円もらいますけど
そのまともな組織は
2万円ぐらいの労力を使ってますね
その 500円のために
だって 資料を渡したり
説明したり
レポートを見せたり
自分たちの
NGO 活動のことを説明したりとかね
日本で有名な方
黒柳さんでしたっけ
いろいろボランティアなさってるでしょ
たとえば　そのような方が
アフリカに行って
パキスタンに行って
ボランティア活動をするんだよと ひとこと言ったら
さっとお金が入っちゃうんですね
あれは何でしょうかね
あれは決してアフリカの人々のことを心配してあげるお金じゃないんです
パキスタンの人のことを本当に心配してあげてるお金じゃないんです
黒柳さんが日本ですごい有名な人で
みんな信頼しているんです
それでその人に接近できたというぐらいのことなんです
そちらにあるのは人気者にヒッチハイクしただけのことで
他の人にはあげませんと
たとえば音楽の人々とか
たった 1時間で何億円も集まるでしょ
福祉の演奏会とかあるでしょうに
たった 1時間 2時間で
そういう有名な人々は何億円でも集めて見せます
だから　その何億円もお金を寄付した人々が
本当に欲を捨てて
慈しみであんなお布施したんですか？
していないんです
ただ 世界一流の人気者にヒッチハイクでしょ
だからあまり徳はないんだと 仏教では言うんですね
人気者と一緒に座ったら どれくらい天国に行けますかね
たとえば黒柳さんと握手をしたんだと
それで天国に行けますか？
だからみんなわかってないのは
人気者にヒッチハイクしたんだから
天国まで行けるってことじゃないんです
だからそこらへんも この騙し機能を使ってるんで
けっして黒柳さんが人を騙してるわけじゃないんです
彼女は自分の意思でボランティア活動をしているだけで
自分の能力を使って
それにみんな大変心を込めて寄付はします
でも調べてみちゃうと
その寄付にはなかなか徳のエネルギーは少ないんですね
ただヒッチハイクしただけだからね
そうやって世の中で我々の場合は この騙し機能が働いているんだということを理解してください
意味あるところはそういうところではなくて
騙し機能では 徳が弱いということなんです
良いことをしたら良い結果があります
でも　この心に騙し機能が働いちゃうと
あまり良い結果が出てこないんですね
ですから
真剣に子どもを育てたはずなのに
子どもが不良になることはあるでしょ
あれはあの結果なんです
奥さんがよく言うでしょ
私は真剣に旦那に尽くしたのに
旦那が不倫しちゃったと
だったら この騙し機能なんです
結果が悪かったらね
自分が騙し機能で生きていたんだということなんですね
残念なことは
その時はもう遅いんです
旦那が不倫して他の女の人のところに行ってしまった時
文句言うでしょ
私はずっと親切に尽くしてきたのに
私のことを裏切ってしまったと
私にそんな話を言ったら
私は説明するでしょ
あなたは本当は旦那様に親切ではなかったと
優しくなかったと
あなたは自分のことしか考えてなかったと
お風呂をわかしてもご飯作っても
だから旦那さんにとっては面白くなかったよと
そういえばそうですねと
今気づいたってもう遅いんだからね
だから騙し機能の場合は
気づくともう遅いんです
だからどうしても騙されちゃう
必ず気をつけないとね
大変なことなんです
それは皆様にあるんだけど
そんなに解決法はないしね
ですから
出家の場合と修行する場合はね
瞑想する場合は
すごく気をつけないと正しく道は進めない
だからでしょう
この宗教家
いきなり世の中を騙すのは
聖なる道歩んでるんだ
歩んでるんだと言いながら
どこかでものすごく権力のために
財産のために
行動しちゃうでしょ
凶暴になって 戦いにまで出ちゃうんですね
法輪功（ファールンゴン）という宗教組織がありますね 中国で
中国政府に対してものすごく攻撃かけてるんですね
我々は平和ばかり喋ってるんだ
ただ修行してるだけだと言いながら
中国政府に対しては攻撃かけてるんですね
それからはもうはっきりとそういうことになっちゃうんです
騙し機能が働いてます
本人さえ知りません
それは騙しだと
彼もブッダみたいですね アメリカで生活してるんだけど
現代ブッダたちはアメリカでなきゃあかんみたいね
ブッダたちいっぱいいるんですけど
一応そういうことで話を終了させていただきます
長い時間どうもありがとうございます